私はねあの昨日の撮影で風邪をひきました
は勝手だけどねちょっと6時だぞと言ってて喉がやられたなぁとその進退的にボロボロ
だったんで
クリスマスの日はもう3ジーコすぐ寝たんですけども寝たきりみたいになっちゃって
売れしますは寝て起きて編集して終わりましたはじめ社長ですよねちょっと家に帰って
くれたちょっと今日はね
ゆるくいきましょう
かわいいな久しぶりに家についてゆっくりしたいとこなんですけどもうちょっとある
情報を入れましてこちらになるとこですけどドーン米ローンねえ皆さんご存知でしょう
かたぶん普通にしてる人が居るんですけどもすっこしといえば
ぬーんっ
と少したり今少し側ですよね受けで側とっておこう
今日はこちらうどんできますドン名になるんですけどもこれはのネット5分って
かえってやりますこれはつまりどん兵衛は悟空の温めると一番おいしいタイミングで
召し上がれますという意味なんですよねこれもどん兵衛に資産を決めたことなんです
けどもうちょっとある情報でですね
やっぱ出てる俺と情報
アデルはいろんな記事があるんですよネット上で10たんで食べたほうが美味しいと
いう話が出ております
日本人なら誰もが一度は口にしたことがあるであろう妊娠のカップどんどんで現在
ベッドではこの同盟の新しい食べ方としてお湯を入れてから通常古墳食べられるところ
を10分待つことで和えて麺を飛びさせて食べる10分ドン目が話題になっております
ということです中でいろんな人が
10分で食べたほうがおいしいと言ってで麺がつるつるになって食感が限りなく7度目
に近づくて話を聞いておりますというわけで今日はどんなこっち2つあるんですけど
もう品の方と10分の方で2つちょっと食べる比べてみたいと思いますこのフード
プロデューサー初めてですねどっちが美味しいかところでちょっとはっきりじゃあ爪と
しようと思いますじゃあちょっとお湯入れていきますこれ十全に気になるタイプ
ああああああ
ああっ
月で風邪ひいたからねみんな風邪には気をつけよう今インフルとか流行っているからさ
少々を持ち寄ったこれキャッチでうまいんだな多分これたぶんすごいですよねが
いろんな人が呟いてたり何か言ったりするみたいで立ちで生まれみたいでやばいなこれ
なんか話題になってるから早くしないと他のユーチューバーもやってしまう俺はいつぞ
えっ背景なきゃ1ネットで話題のどうぞ
youtube
あって求道だしますからね早めにやっとこ youtube 見たけどまだ誰もやって
ませんん
若菜強い待って本年ちゃまやってたらどうして他の湯千葉やって太郎が他の
youtube へ行ってただけだっ
たまにやってる人が
はいお花とツアーかやってる何か言ってるけど俺あまあこのビッグウェーブに乗るしか
ない
まだまだ間に合うまだ間に合うぞをがやりますからね先に
ガーッということは先に10分 cell 4に入れましょう
はい皆先に10分する方に入れますおよ5分経ったのにこっち入れてちょうど10分
経ったら国に立ったというわけでございますでは言えていきましょう
じゃあ今日の夜ご飯だよ中国ユーチューバーより早い他のユーチューバーでかいこっち
は10分ですこちら10分
タイマーっ短波帯はなんで普通に
だそうそうタイマーで10分当たりましたそれで満足で音源たったとに骨に入れますよ
止めだけ緩かったがちょっと差が出ちゃうからこれは his 月羽希します
でまぁもちろんせあっはい iphone でつく
ではどんどん作ってるから電話するかじゃねぇどうしたってちょっとアップ族
授業前
こういう配合させました feed 恥女ハイパワー
あっはぁもうちょっとでございます431ちゃーん
ファイルで関連しましたーこっちが10分の女こっちがノーマルの国にどんどんで
ございますそれって良いよ
よしっぱにめ来ました配布ない国家はい
なんかのレビュー今回まだ10分どん兵衛の方ねちょっと見ていきましょうちょっとね
麺が太いんですよねちょっとのことで麺が太い気がしますはいもうまるごん at 本
目ですまあまあこっちょ
の太さです輪っか伝わるかなぁ大前大事なのはここから10分断片と古墳同盟どっちが
美味しいかっていうのがやっぱり一番大事なのでさっそく食べてみようと思いますまず
は10分の命の方
やっぱなんかコシがあるつるつるしてンって言っていただきます
ちょっと比べてみなきゃわかんないこれぞ美味しいですが午前の方
なぁアオジ感じねぇ
a うーん
ああああああ
はいこっちの総理でございますあのね僕はですねあの食べればいいみたいなちょっとあ
存知なところあるんですけどもちょっとやっぱり違いが分かりました5分待つと音をし
てのインスタント加賀くるじゃん過去はないというかちょっとはおかしいぽい感じが
残ってて美味しいんですけどバッド黒こうなんかお菓子っぽさが残りますあのアズ弾い
てるときのうどんって美味しいんだよまずこれに対して10
の上バー水もしっかり吸収していてあれば麺がつるつるしてるんですよ生麺みたいな
感じでなんか本番の本場のうどんみたいな感じがしますなんて真面目なレビューだ自分
でもびっくりするぐらい今日は真面目だった米10数人で食べてみなかったってアジア
結局変わんないんですけども面倒感じがかなり変わりますどっちも美味しいからどっち
でもいいと思う
ます
ええええええ
tee
いいしています